lots of big news today we finally got a
ps5
price and release date final fantasy 16
has been announced and also a new
splinter cell game on the oculus quest
2.
i'm chastity and this is your save state
for wednesday let's jump in
today's ps5 showcase had a lot to offer
and it finally revealed the next gen
console's price and release date
playstation 5 is launching on november
12th in the us japan
canada mexico australia new zealand and
south korea
and on november 19th in the rest of the
world it's 499 us dollars for the
standard console and 399 us dollars for
an all digital version with no disk
drive
with comparable pricing in each region
check game spot for specifics if you
need them the stream also revealed the
playstation plus collection which
featured a list of popular ps4 games
like god of war
persona 5 days gone until dawn and a
bunch more
ps plus members can download and play
these games on ps5 on day one
the stream closed with an announcement
of a god of war sequel
focused on ragnarok coming in 2021 but
that's all we know about it right now
the spider-man miles morales gameplay
was also another personal highlight for
me what was your favorite part of the
ps5 conference let me know in the
comments
now let's dial it back and talk about a
major game reveal in detail the ps5
event opened with a trailer for final
fantasy 16.
we saw a bunch of combat in the trailer
which looked similar to the combat in
final fantasy xv and final fantasy vii
remake
in final fantasy 16 you play as joshua
bodyguard to the son of the archduke in
a world being infected by some sort of
blight the trailer showed some classic
final fantasy summons including shiva
and titan the footage shown was from the
pc version of the game but it's going to
be a ps5 console exclusive
slated to release in 2021 also i would
like to know more about this dog that
appeared at the beginning of the trailer
what a good boy ps5 wasn't the only
event today there was also the 2020
facebook connect event which gave us
some big announcements for the oculus
vr headset the oculus quest 2 releases
on october 13th there's a 64 gigabyte
model for 299 dollars and a 256 gigabyte
model for 399
with this new and improved standalone
headset facebook is moving away from pc
reliant headsets
so the oculus rift is being phased out
so what can you play on the quest
too ubisoft announced assassin's creed
and splinter cell vr games
they were developed by redstorm who made
star trek bridge crew
there's no game names or dates and
that's all we know for now but there
hasn't been a new splinter cell game
since 2013's blacklist so that's pretty
cool
and that's your save state for wednesday
i'm chastity and you can find me on
twitter at chastity underscore v come
back tomorrow for more news and i'll see
you next time
you